hello i'm chris holden president of the  five to the home council europe  this has been a great show for us and  one of the things that stands out in my  mind is the camaraderie and all the  communications happening within the  exhibition area  this is very important to us because  we're a member organization  and it's great to see not only the fact  that we have three thousand people here  but they're going around the exhibition  and really talking with all the members  at their standards  for me this is an excellent show hello  my name is hardwick tauber i'm the  director general of the ftth council  europe  milan  it's the 8th edition of the ftdh  conference it's 3 000 people and i just  can't say one thing it's great